former president Trump reacting for the
first time just moments ago after
pleading not guilty to 37 counts
relating to his handling of classified
documents watch here how did it go are
we getting I think it's going great okay
let's make it to a rig deal here we have
a rigged country we have a country
that's corrupt we have a country that's
got no borders we have a country that's
got nothing but problems We're a nation
and Decline and then they do this stuff
and you see where the people are we love
the people and you see where they are
you see the crowds and everything else
we have a country that is in Decline
like never before and we can't let it
happen and we're getting brand new
sketches from inside the court where
Trump became the first former president
to be arraigned on federal charges he
was electronically fingerprinted but
there was no mug shot he was not
handcuffed and the former president's
team says the prosecution is political
and as Chief antagonist Adam Schiff and
Hillary Clinton are attacking
Republicans for defending Trump
I want to call out a separate National
Security at risk and that is with all of
these you know Republican Presidential
hopefuls attacking the justice
department calling this illegitimate
even those who are criticizing the
president are still criticizing the
department the response that we've seen
in polling from Republicans
um suggests that they're going to stick
with him that it's more of a cult than a
political party at this point and
they're going to stick with their leader
wow she never learns I had not heard her
say that okay we'll get to that in a
second
um judge feel free to comment on
anything on the court or not I can't
believe she just said that she never
learns the Durham report came down what
three weeks ago and said she made up the
Russia collusion Oaks she told Biden and
she told something insulted calling them
the deplorables
and she hates us I mean if you support
Donald Trump you're part of a cult I
mean you have no control over yourself
look I I think today was a I think it
was a sad day for America I I really do
I think that you know if if you kind of
look at it from thirty thousand feet you
have the most popular candidate running
for president in the United States a
former president himself being indicted
by as special counsel uh that works
under the indictment and under the
administration and needs the approval of
the attorney general for to get this
indictment uh which administration's
president wants to run against this now
defendant in a serious criminal case
I've said from the time we first heard
this last week
um you know I don't believe that any
documents have been destroyed I haven't
heard that anyone was given access to
documents and I think that the the broad
brush Espionage claim is something that
you know Americans instinctively and
intuitively feel that oh my God he's
anti-American well I you know I don't
know of anyone who is who is uh more
pro-american but
um there is no evidence no one's saying
it's spite of the fact that they got the
narrative out there before the
indictment was even unsealed we knew
everything that was going on before it
was unsealed before the defendant was
arraigned we had this narrative we found
out how many top secret secret
confidential etc etc and yet there is no
indication that there was any harm harm
is an essential element to the crime of
Espionage I want to say that again harm
Espionage otherwise you're dealing with
the presidential records act which was
created in 78 because Johnson and the
rest of them couldn't figure out what
was a presidential record and what
wasn't and this is now the criminal
because Nixon had all the boxes loaded
up and uh Johnson or Ford was like oh is
that allowed I don't know if that should
be allowed and so they yes you're right
right so they passed along they figured
it out but I just want to say a couple
more things
um we've got a prosecutor whose
reputation has been subtle solid by the
United States Supreme Court and juries
across this country but you also have a
guy who's promising a speedy trial in a
case that involves classified documents
Trump is not up to speed right now in
terms of his representation he needs
attorneys uh who are classified document
uh approved so for example you would
have to have a death penalty defense
attorney who has the credentials in a
death penalty case the same in a
classified documents case this is going
to take a long time and
um in the end I think it is
um it's almost laughable that we're
going through this right now with
absolutely no indication of harm where
the standard is harmed to the country
Jessica one thing about this is I think
that people on the Republican side would
say well clearly there's a double
standard if you're a Clinton then you
don't get prosecuted if you're a
Republican and if you're Trump
especially you're going to get
prosecuted what about that
double standard that Americans feel and
also could you comment on do you think
that Hillary Clinton is insane for what
she just said
so I'll go with the second one first I
don't think that Hillary Clinton is
insane I would never use the term
deplorable again obviously that was
something she said almost worse she said
they're in a cult
I don't think it's a cult but I think
that Donald Trump holds
an almost mystical level of power and
control over a large swath of the
Republican base and they are immune to
taking in new information new negative
information new dangerous information
new potentially criminal information
about him and so to that sense I
understand what she was trying to say
but obviously it's going to be cut off
it's going to use the sound box that's
no good
um a couple of things so the
presidential records act and Andy
McCarthy was talking about this earlier
today it doesn't apply to agency
documents so the way that people are
using this to say I think you said it
yesterday Jesse oh you know he's allowed
to do this he's not allowed to do it and
there are little experts
yeah it is a good argument that he's not
allowed to have those documents he can't
decide when he classifies them he
admitted that on tape which is going to
be a huge piece of evidence in this so
stop using the presidential records I
will use that act whenever I damn well
please we'll continue to do it
inaccurately in terms of the I said I
printed it out thank God I printed it
out because I'm about to smack you with
the act in a second let me talk about
the Espionage Act so this isn't classic
Espionage within the Espionage Act there
are a lot of things included
most importantly unauthorized retention
of documents and obstruction of justice
which it seems pretty clear that they
have them on and again legal experts
both sides of the aisle people who have
defended Trump multiple times like
Jonathan Turley have said when I said
this on Friday as well that these are
the Darlings what they're looking for in
order to have
um is it a sad day yes in one sense it's
always that I guess to see a president
in this position but what's more sad I
think is that we had a president who did
these things and when everyone says this
is unprecedented the problem is that
Donald Trump is doing things that are
unprecedented and we don't know that
these documents weren't compromised we
heard about that there were two
Intruders to Chinese National Intruders
we know that he waved around a
classified document in front of Mark
Meadows now you care about Chinese
Nationals what are you the amount of
deflection that goes on when I say I say
something about China and you go Fang
Fang or I say something about this and
then you just throw it 100 Biden's a
crack addict who cares talk about what
happened today talk about the indictment
and don't make up things use legal
experts that's a good transition just to
talk about but before I get into the ACT
which I have right here you said
something that the Trump voters are
immune from taking in new information
that's such BS Jessica because we're
actually learning about the presidential
records act we're learning about the
Espionage Act and we're actually making
legal arguments and using precedent and
comparisons to how the justice
department has treated Democrats so the
fact you're saying like we're just kind
of like oh you know I don't want to know
you're the ones that want to don't want
to take in any new information you're
the ones when you show bank records of
the Chinese lining the pockets of nine
Biden families you don't even want to
talk about it you don't want to
acknowledge the fact that there could be
tapes of Joe Biden talking to the
original executive that the FBI has
buried that there has been a five
million dollar bribe allegation your
hear no evil see no evil don't point
fingers at the right and say you're a
cult when your side won't even wrestle
Within any of the facts okay now here's
the ACT this is an Obama judge by the
way the quote under the statutory scheme
established by the presidential records
act the decision to segregate personal
materials from presidential records is
made by the president at his sole
discretion let me finish when Bill
Clinton took these records from the
White House back to Chappaqua the active
self of taking them home to his home
made them personal records it says
there's no permission in the act that
even permits the archivist to assume
control over anything that's personal
and if he did have a decent legal team
they would have just squashed The
subpoena immediately with the
presidential records act and you're
going to hear it litigated in federal
court in Miami so don't act like this is
some sort of Slam Dunk case you'll
probably lose you'll probably appeal
it'll go to the Supreme Court and there
is no way in hell the Supreme Court is
going going to uphold a conviction of a
former president possibly current
president over where a piece of paper
goes it's not there's no dead body
there's no bribes there's nothing
I'm dying to hear what Greg Gutfeld has
I don't have much to say Dana and all
honestly I was busy yeah yes but I just
want I just want someone to look at me
the way the sketch artist looked at
Donald Trump yeah I am we'd all be a lot
thinner I would look amazing with that
sketch artist look the big question
really is motive the obvious answer
there wasn't one right carelessness or
ignorance isn't a motive it could be
unlawful violation of a process but the
idea that he had this intent to commit
treason is obviously a political line of
thinking the bottom line is you just
can't indict over carelessness a
president even if you can right you may
be able to do it but you shouldn't and I
get it politics dictates that you should
destroy people but patriotism would say
don't destroy a president you know move
on get on with your life if this
indictment had caused some kind of
damage I mean if the crimes that they're
indicting them on had caused some damage
or some injury I get it but it didn't so
this punishment is for a different crime
and that crime is being Donald Trump
that's all this is it's like and we know
this he plays outside the game he
doesn't know when to stop he plays by
his own rules there are risks involved
and this is one of the risks why what I
find interesting about him
is you know he stops at a cafe he plays
golf
you ever get the feeling that his world
is a video game and he's the main player
and everybody around him trying to make
his life hell or NPCs you know
non-playing characters who just provide
him with challenges so he just makes it
more difficult to see if he can get to
the next level I don't see him sweating
about this I don't even know if he under
I don't even know if he has a pulse when
it comes to this sort of thing because
it's just part of being that life and
these are not big these are not big
issues there are other things in life
but we're going to do it because it's
the summer we got to talk about
something can I just comment I know that
it's supposed to be my block and I ask
the questions but I just have to say
something about Hillary Clinton so the
the deplorables comment it actually was
probably one of the most horrible
political decisions when she said that
initially and they've continued it and
then to add that on today in a moment
where Joe Biden is basically in the
I was gonna say toilet is that fair is
there event approval ratings and they're
trying to figure out a way to find swing
voters that will come back to them and
that basically that's saying that the
elite Democrats they do not like you and
she is reconfirming it I think if I were
them I would say Hillary thank you for
your service we are good here go enjoy
the grandchildren but they don't want to
be murdered Dana I'm we're gonna have to
put extra security on you on the way
maybe on me yes I think I might need it
it's just like I was just so shocked by
that I hadn't heard it yet all right I
want to Brian kill Mead I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now